hi there Steve here again it's holiday
here but I'm gonna stick to my regular
schedule putting out these videos um
today I want to talk about now my last
video I said you know content is king
and I and I said that this is this idea
that developing the ability to notice is
one of the ingredients of success in
language learning and then I said but
I've come to realize that that the
ability to notice develops naturally if
you get exposed to enough content of
course one of the problems with with
content is of course at an early stage
there isn't much compelling content that
you can actually understand so that's
where you get integrated readers you get
into some of the many stories we have at
link I have said it would be great to
have more conversations if people would
contribute conversations that could be
transcribed maybe we have a website
somewhere that people put up
conversations in different languages
that's kind of a bit of a dream that I
have but but another thing about why
emphasize today is one thing that I find
very important in language learning is
variety you know covering the same
ground by a different you know from
different directions different textbooks
different beginning you know start your
books and so forth and so I wanted to
put in a plug today for this a similar
version that I picked up in Montreal it
is very good and there are many people
who swear by us email I found them
somewhat indifferent it depends on the
language I like the Russian one the Arab
one is okay
I find the content a little bit
artificial but the Persian one is very
good and so I'm combining this with my
mini stories so with the many stories I
get exposed to a lot of vocabulary I get
a sense of the rhythm of the language
but there are things about how the verbs
work in Persian which doesn't come out
of just doing many stories so I'm
exposed to it and now I'm sort of ready
to get a bit of an explanation of how
these verbs work verbs that I've already
been exposed to and so the great thing
with combining my mini stories with
where
my way through this is that with each
little item of you know text that they
provide they provide little explanations
I also bought a book I think it's living
language which is a terrible book to
many exercises lots of heavy explanation
things that you aren't going to remember
I think in Chapter two they give you all
the possible relatives uncle aunt cousin
runt mother-in-law father-in-law all
this kind of stuff that's very difficult
to remember and not all that compelling
let's say so I think the main point that
I want to make today is that you know
with regard to anything I noticed there
was some discussion about the importance
of speaking early my good friend Ollie
Richards says he finds it very
stimulating to speak early it triggers
you know neural connections or whatever
it might be all of this is true but and
so to the extent that you can mix in
some conversation that's good too but
the issue is how do you do that so if
you don't have much of the language you
can't just accost someone in the street
you basically have to pay a tutor or you
have a very good friend who will speak
to you and then the next question is
then what are you gonna talk about so
again in the case of my Farsi I base it
on my mini story so I read in the mini
stories and I might even make a give you
a video of me reading in Farsi and then
answering questions in Farsi about what
I just read so at least I have some body
of vocabulary that where I have the
words and I understand what it's all
about but we couldn't have an unprepared
conversation because I just don't have
enough experience and of course Ronna my
tutor she's a tutor at link so I pay her
so sure you can you can pay someone to
speak to you early or you can simply
spend more time listening and reading
and varying your activities the way I do
link I read my little mini stories I
review the words I listen in the car I
read a bit of us email all of those
things once I got the book you know I
can do as much of it as I want and so I
don't have to deliberately arranged a
meeting with a tutor however in the case
of Farsi I am finding it great
especially since we don't have
text-to-speech and I simply don't know
how some words are pronounced I find it
very good to have that session with with
Rana in Farsi so I think one important
rule in language learning is variate mix
it up don't get too stuck in dogmatic
positions and try to enjoy it and
usually with enough time and and
exposure you will eventually reach your
goals bye for now
[Music]